william scusa di attivarsi andiamo un
attimo in bagno
e un massaggio la mandibola mi sono
sentito un po esposto sessualmente
troppo presto era troppo presto per me
lei del resto diciamo che ha unito i
puntini ad esempio ho dimenticato delle
riviste pornografiche game bagno questo
la insospettita una donna forte intuito
ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una puntata
evita buttata oggi mi farò un tè in
compagnia di immanuel casto benvenuto
ciao grazie mille per le indie allora tu
sappi invio è da anni che sogno di
conoscerti ma troppo gennaio è vero
perché rappresenti una serie di realtà
delle quali io sono fan o soffritti
qualcosa da bere perché sia un en al
tasso lutamente guarda quindi tutti i
drink sono altri poi noi in realtà anni
addietro ci siamo velocemente sfiorati
la mano li ho conosciuti hai seguito di
un dei versetti media award
velocemente salutare però se non abbiamo
avuto così vedete resta molto più esteso
e più esteso ma comunque protetto è la
bellissima manualità ne sarebbe già
caduto tutto perdono i pezzi di ghiaccio
più grossi cade mai visto anche questa è
una manualità non so se noi adesso
diverso cioè c'è un brindisi e milan ci
di una puntata
[Musica]
il momento certo
e allora eccoci siamo pronti per una
nuova puntata di vita buttata
[Musica]
allora innanzitutto complimenti perché
quando vedete è il nuovo gioco che hai
lanciato grembo pet che è dolcissimo
grazia diciamo che è una novità
all'interno del parterre dei giochi che
i sensi giuro dopo 13 anni a parlare di
prostituzione droga
le fusa in amante dei gatti si più dei
cani quello fu un accordo ma anche per
questioni estetiche
cioè trovi che il cane sia più bello del
gatto perdonami era una locuzione 3
portabile due fasi colturali più dei
cani i gatti più decani tu sei più
amante dei cani si evoca pitto ti piace
legati più dei cani hanno assolutamente
l'esatto opposto non ho tutta la vita i
gatti più belli dei cani è notevolmente
sia parte qualche eccezione ed è qui che
si apre un dibattito già nei commenti
qui sotto fateci sapere se the thing
atti ottimi cani i tuoi gatti o due
gatti ovviamente io due gatti un cane io
penso sempre che se i due gatti da un
minuto all'altro sparissero io vivere
sereno c'è il mio cane non beve io entro
nel panico sono esattamente la matrigna
che è tendenzialmente ha un figlio
preferito lo capisco per me così con uno
dei due gatti domani so che esce
malcostume fra l'altro nel disco ci sono
anche diverse presenze alcune delle
quali sono state proprio anche ospiti in
questa deliziosa casetta tra cui le
karma b che stupendo e poi c'è una terza
ma scopriamo dopo aver ascoltato questa
audio ragazzi ciao vi racconto questa
che è bellissima stagione animazione
citò praticamente che con il codice
il rapporto sessuale col preservativo
però fit rapporto sessuale non si trova
il preservativo giovane dopo le mi dice
anni fa un po male qui mi fa un po male
qui e faceva beh se è stata una serata
movimentata chi sta sotto tre giorni
continua di quadri sui giu il quarto
giorno un animatore viene da meglio mi
diceva tu hai fatto sesso
nel toccarle nelle carla ho trovato
qualcosa di tuo che gli era rimasto
dentro anche a me è capitato di smarrire
delle cose detto che emergevano prima di
quattro giorni io conosco una ragazza
aveva fatto sesso con questo ragazzo su
4 5 giorni dopo da roma se ne ritorna a
milano dove sta con la famiglia fa il
bagno tutto quanto compagnia bella esce
bagno e tra un presentativo per terra e
si domanda i genitori settantenni e ha
iniziato a cioè a 70 anni queste
posizioni ammessi a chiamare duro e
buttare preservativi ma entra nel panico
e realizza quel preservativo invece l'ha
portato dai può capitare nel sesso anale
ma difficilmente non te ne rendi conto
nonostante siano 12 metri
esattamente invece gente si perde nella
magia di tutto di più ma infatti a un
luogo che io non fra quanto anche per
questo aveva ora di perdermi ti confesso
che io amo fare degli scherzi di dubbio
gusto e io abito a bologna e sono
adiacente ad un albergo non ti spiego
l'esatta logistica ma ti dico che dal
balcone della mia camera più affaccio
sulla finestra dell'hotel proprio
completamente adiacente ora sono due
cose che facevo insomma nei miei
vent'anni un po burlone no capitava
insomma dopo aver avuto un rapporto
insert ivo e sfilare un preservativo
facevo il noto perché comunque sono
signore dopodiché lo gettava dentro
questa stanza in vi piaceva l'idea che
le persone svegliandosi trovassero un
preservativo pieno ai piedi
un gavettone anche con tanto di nodino
per evitare l'inutile
e la reception allo stesso tempo pensa
ci siano dei problemi della coppia sono
tutte cose a cui non posso assistere
purtroppo la cosa che mi fa soffrire
sono tutti lì tutta la notte dal balcone
così a vedere che cosa succedeva
presa discreta uno che lancia un
preservativo senti parlando invece di
una cosa che a me piace un sacco della
tua vita se il presidente del mensa che
cos'è il mensa immensa e la più
importante associazione mondiale
internazionale per persone con alto qui
ossia da diventare soci o socio è
necessario superare un test di
intelligenza logico spaziale non ti
tengo una lezione su cosa sia
l'intelligenza anche perché non c'è una
definizione univoca diciamo
sommariamente che il cui è un indice che
ci va a raccontare in qualche modo le
abilità logiche e il tuo cui quante
allora di solito preferisco non parlare
di dimensioni di serie è abbastanza
sopra la media ma io potrei fare questo
test farlo si ma passarlo ci possiamo
dare dentro adesso assolutamente sì
voglio assistere ai tuoi ragionamenti
non c'è bisogno che tu li verbali si io
capirò guardando la tua faccia per ora
sta andando benissimo sono semplici ma
c'è chi ci mette più tempo le cappelle
andiamo con una cappella bianca secondo
me è il tuo cuore però sapeva già
approvata a posto ad ogni modo ti
assicuro che sta andando bene stare
risaliti quel liceo ci stava un tipo
sull'autobus un sacco e ci troviamo
sempre i vostri sguardi profondi
quindi un giorno eravamo già dalle forte
insomma stava a lui 50 va ai giovani già
in possesso del matrimonio e non che a
una certa la porta dietro dimessi altri
io finisco con il culo sul marciapiede
dentro una pozzanghera imbarazzo totale
questo rileva tutto l'aiuto boost righe
ma è la
wd store nel torneo del coraggio di dire
[Risate]
che a volte ci arrivano questi messaggi
che sto tipo a e adesso comunque abbiamo
due figli e nel racconto straziante era
molto triste però secondo me anche un
romanzo di formazione non certo senso 1
sono impazzito del tecnico atto poi ci
sono io mi ricordo che andava a dormire
e mi facevo tipo le fanta pippe su cosa
sarebbe potuto succedere il giorno dopo
di meraviglioso a scuola insieme questo
mi ha portato poi in realtà avere più un
ragazzo a vent'anni capiscono o di cotte
adolescenziali scolastiche ne ho avute
parecchie fra l'altro credo di essere
stato il primo studente out del liceo
artistico statale di bergamo out due
rehau tempra 11 anni si e se i tuoi come
la presero scusami solitamente non
faccio questa domanda me la son curioso
mia madre me l'ha chiesto lei tra
l'altro che fin troppo presto nel senso
che col senno di poi avrei preferito
avesse aspettato perché non ero pronto a
parlarne lei me l'ha chiesto 14 anni
dicendo guarda la premessa che io amo
tutti i miei figli o altri due fratelli
a prescindere dalle loro caratteristiche
questo si deve essere chiaro però ho
paura che tu possa soffrire per via di
una caratteristica di cui invece vorrei
insomma poter parlare e diminuisce la
domanda mi sono sentito un po esposto
sessualmente troppo presto era troppo
presto per me lei del resto diciamo che
ha unito i puntini ad esempio ho
dimenticato delle riviste pornografiche
di bagno questo la insospettita una
donna di forte intuito i segni non erano
tutti lì insomma se è molto credibile a
questa cosa
[Musica]
e che si chiamano il diminutivo mano
mano nessuno ti ha mai in mano in mano
poi ma abbiamo queste domande si tu dove
farmene una dopo l'altra si e li dovrò
velocissimo rispondere appena tu
definisci premi il saltarello e subito
facciamo cambio e io dovrò rispondere
con lo stesso tono col quale viene fatta
la domanda giusto che cazzo vuol dire
non lo so quanti abitanti al paris
nessuno
sesso fra di loro qual è il miglior modo
per abbracciare qualcuno dietro posso
conto con un euro l'amore dove si
nascondono i bambini a casa di michael
jordan vero quanto pesa una foca 83
chili e mezzo di chi è la colpa tua
quanto altro l'uomo più alto del mondo 2
metri e 30 nomi nel posto più bello in
assoluto
finito il gelato sicuramente io dimmi un
ceduto in una lingua llonto e dragos dei
cantoni una canzone
liber liber liber live è un disastro se
non me la dai
perché il sole caldo per che scotta
perché gli arcobaleni sono così belli
per ispirare gli omosessuali finito così
ci porterà a casa abbiamo sentito c'è
nella prima storia oggetti persi nella
vagina nella seconda storia un culo che
è caduto sul marciapiede
la magia dei buchi o direi tra l'altro
ti possa raccontare che in questo
momento io no 2
di buchi devi sapere che io soffro di
lombosciatalgia quindi sono molto
propenso al cosiddetto colpo della
strega vivendo da solo e chi ha questi
problemi lo sa estremamente invalidante
proprio non ti muovi più non riesce a
farne in quel momento di vermi
completamente rimanendo non riesce a far
niente ho imparato a farmi le inizioni
da solo l'ultima volta ho sbagliato
qualcosa e non l'ho fatta abbastanza
intero muscolo quindi s'è creata questa
gomma di farmaco io non sapevo potesse
succedere mi ha sciolto il derma io
adesso ho un cratere che sto trattando è
una cosa veramente antiestetica e che
dico molto male
alle superiori
agli anni che vi fermarci alla
rosticceria di fronte un altro liceo con
ordinari intanto zone in giro e all'alta
luce tipo esclusività questo caso
nulla che non capiti spesso la clerici
io per quanto mi riguarda ho sempre
preferito canzone con una comicità ormai
speech era quasi dei film di de sica e
allora io mi lancerò dicendo sai che io
invece non amo particolarmente o
l'onestà di riconoscere i meriti e le
implicazioni di ergonomia del fallo però
non lo amo esteticamente pirlo qual è un
tuo dettagli lo facciamo tutti quanti
questa domanda una cosa che tu noti e
una cosa che trovi sexy stando sul
convenzionale c'è una cosa che trovo
bella è che gli occhi se andiamo sul
fisico invece nel caso di un uomo petto
spalle sexy quindi entriamo nel fetish
ma spesso nel fetish funziona così se la
persona ti piace ti piace tantissimo se
non ti piace è una roba che proprio non
vuoi vedere a ok l'ascella nel mio caso
rom una una cosa bella
non so se un po forse un po superficie
l'altezza l'altezza in generale mi dice
delle cose mi racconta delle cose
l'altezza a livello sexy e che non può
essere giusto non si può dire
è banale si parte così
io trovo forse che la cosa più sexy sia
proprio parte che non sono sorpreso
perché la testuale frase che ha
connotato il tuo che uno dei cani gatti
piu famosi della storia d'italia è vero
tra parentesi il giochetto lo facciamo
anche qua sotto fateci sapere qual è la
cosa che guarda di più del partner o
comunque nel sesso nella persona che vi
interessa è quella che la parte che
invece trovati più sexy
ma disparità bordata sala verdi sono la
mia dopo due anni di compleanno chiusani
zona rossa piano lo davano fatto il 30 e
31 così quest'anno che sono libera
nessuno dico nessuno si è fatto vivo
praticamente opposto il compleanno da
sola in casa con la figlia di 4 anni il
board dei cartoni ma nel senso che lei
ha fatto gli inviti nessuno si è
presentato sembra di capire che non
abbia una fitta rete sociale prescindere
se tu riesci a dare una dignità e una
dolcezza delle cose che sono sola come
un cane guarda in questa chiacchierata
estremamente ridanciana e qui c'è
sicuramente hai la capacita di spingere
verso il basso la barra io mi impegno
poi a cercare di andare sempre più
nell'abisso
talento io sono veramente un diplomatico
se tu mi dici ma mai devo comunicare una
merla mi dice come confezionarla facci
un lavoretto che la persona ti ringrazia
dopo averla ricevuta veramente ne so
confezionare veramente di allora aspetta
aspetta ora tutte
dimmi i messaggi dove comunicare io te
l'ho confezioni mi stai sul caxxo
facciamo che la trasferta che ci
guardiamo non ci salviamo
ti prego lasciami paese e un po ecco a
voi chiudere un rapporto non è mai
dimenticare chiudere un rapporto si ma
si può chiudere il rapporto cosa ti
interessa che messaggio finirà
comunicato bene ho investito il tuo cane
del dialetto è la madonna ma non sono
critiche alicia scusa ci possiamo sedere
un ateo liceo veramente non so come
dirtelo sono veramente veramente
mortificato ieri ho sentito sbattere con
la mia macchina sono sceso a guardare e
si trattava della tua cambia
veramente cosa dire mi dispiace
tantissimo non è una critica
semplicemente devi far capire che ti
dispiace vorrei che quando tamo mi
tratti più da
sé un po un santarellino puritano quindi
come faccio a farti capire che vorrei
che uscisse una parte più animalesca
selvaggia arte modo al fatto che le
critiche utili sono incentrate sul
comportamento osservato e non sulla
personalità tu hai già fatto un commento
sulla personalità quindi sospetti che la
persona non sia adatta a te ti potresti
non poterci fare nulla però facciamo un
tentativo lo approcci ovviamente in
privato che a questo punto allora devi
essere innanzitutto specifico non puoi
dire fai sempre così perché non voglio
niente neanche spesso devi dire allora
sai l'altra sera mentre stavamo facendo
sesso ct una cosa specifica hai fatto
questa cosa allora guarda a mi piace
come effettivamente tu fai sesso mi
trovo bene solamente che vorrei anche
esplorare un altra direzione non so se a
te ad esempio possa tu hai mai provato
però per me sarebbe importante
esplorarla e sentirmi a volte come una
cagna
ultimo ultimo ultimo modo di ballo
bravissimo bravo questo quello che
volevo ok questa è perfetta perché è
proprio il modo in cui non darla alla
critica perché sempre distratto non
ascolti mai quindi se una
generalizzazione è delegata fra l'altro
a un tratto della personalità giuliano
scuse attivazione diamo un attimo in
bagno 9 mag
un assaggio la mandibola onesto grazia
che si è preso un attimo in questo
momento da parlare con me allora l'altro
giorno in riunione ho visto che guardavi
spesso il telefono e a causa di questo
poi dopo ti abbiamo dovuto spiegare
delle cose che viviamo già detto in
riunione il che ha fatto perdere tempo
alle altre persone la prossima volta poi
per piacere magari tenerlo in tasca e
non guardare il telefono ti offende una
roba del genere stella dico mi offende
sempre chiamati in bagno per dire di
questo
ma l'obiettivo non è che la critica sia
indolore che vada in porto questo tipo
di critica sono come delle iniezioni non
quelle che faccio io che mia madre nelle
cose che culo deve essere indolore
veloce comune dare il messaggio che
serve ed è con questa edizione d diciamo
etica io ti ringrazio davvero per essere
stato mio ospite a mi ha fatto piacere a
fare questa chiacchiera ma spese anche
per me è stato un vero piacere tra
l'altro tempo testo meraviglioso
ti ringrazio e vi ringrazio hai un tour
anche tu che ora parte
giudici al disco e tra due giorni si
parte con la prima data al magnolia di
milano sia un tour estivo in diverse
città i locali molto bene ragazzi qua
sotto trovate il link per acquistare e
soprattutto vedere quali sono tutte
quante le danni quindi 900 salto se se
ne avete piacere che dire ti ringrazio
in via tutti quanti voi non ci rivediamo
sempre qui
ma non so quando ci piace anche così
ciao ragazzi
[Musica]